you  i'm nick gillespie of reason TV and i  want to tell you a tale more frightening  the michelle obama at a fat farm chew on  this if you can in more than 8 of 10  occupations federal workers make more in  straight salary than their private  sector counterparts and they average  about four times as much in other  benefits such as health care and  pensions a federal janitor makes six  thousand dollars more than his private  sector counterpart and a federal nurse  makes eleven thousand dollars more than  her counterpart at the state local level  public sector workers do pretty well too  in michigan for instance public sector  workers make about forty seven percent  more in total compensation than private  sector working stiffs while taxpayer  budgets are stretched tighter than nancy  pelosi's eyebrows public payrolls are  looser than joe biden's lips